Was ist los in der 2. Liga der Männer? Diese Frage wollen wir jetzt beantworten und wir legen ein Fokus auf den HSV und Schalke 04 mit Torsten Wieland von 1000Freunde.de und Thomas Hürner von der SZ. Nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Und das 1 zu 0.
Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl. Es ist Zeit, endlich mal wieder über die 2. Liga der Männer zu sprechen. Warum es diese Sendung erst jetzt gibt, alle diejenigen, die die letzten Wochen im Rasenfunk verfolgt haben, das lag am Tod von Kai Bernstein. Es hat sich nicht so ganz richtig angefühlt, nach diesem einschneidenden Erlebnis ganz normal mit dem Sportlichen weiterzumachen und das irgendwie kurz in einem härteren Segment abzuhandeln. Deswegen ist ein langes Tribüngespräch erschienen am letzten Montag, an diesem Montag sogar zum Tod von Kai Bernstein. Wir arbeiten ausführlich auf, wer er eigentlich war und für was er stand und was mit ihm dem deutschen Fußball verloren gegangen ist. Das haben schon sehr viele von euch da draußen gehört. Ganz herzlichen Dank für das überwältigende Feedback. Selten eine so positive Rückmeldungswelle bekommen. Also das könnt ihr sehr gerne hören im Tribüngespräch-Feed. Und damit aber habe ich auch wieder ein besseres Gefühl damit, jetzt dann in die sportliche Betrachtung dieser Rückrunde zu gehen, weil wir dem Ganzen eine eigene Sendung gewidmet haben. Und das wollen wir jetzt tun. Wir wollen gucken auf die ersten drei Rückrundenspiele. Thomas, du bist hier von der SZ. Ich freue mich total, dass du dein Debüt gibst im Rasenfunk. Was war denn für dich die größte Überraschung dieser bisherigen drei Spiele?
Ja, die Ehre ist ganz beinerseits. Das soll jetzt nicht klingen, als würde ich mich für allwissend oder so halten. Aber überrascht hat mich ehrlich gesagt gar nichts im neuen Jahr. Also St. Pauli weiter stabil, der HSV weiter wankelmütig. Die Mannschaften dahinter haben vielleicht auch nicht ganz die Qualität, um diesen beiden oder vor allem St. Pauli dann eben auch gefährlich zu werden. Und auch bei Hertha und Schalke haben sich eher Tendenzen verstetigt, finde ich. Deswegen, ich bin leider überraschungsfrei hier erschienen.
Ist das so? Die haben nicht mal der eine Punkt, den Fortuno Düsseldorf in drei Spielen gesammelt hat oder auch der eine Punkt, den Hertha in drei Spielen gesammelt hat. Auch das hatte ich beides nicht überrascht.
Hertha weniger als Düsseldorf, aber auch das passt irgendwie zu Düsseldorf und der Zeit mit Daniel Thun, dass es eben auch mal solche kleinen schwäche Perioden gibt, die, finde ich, auch von der Qualität gedeckt sind, die jetzt nicht ganz an das heranreicht, was eben in der 2. Liga oberste Klasse ist.
Okay, ich sehe schon, hier bringt jemand nichts aus dem ins Wanken. Torsten, wie ist es bei dir?
Ja, man konnte jetzt ja schon prima hören, dass der Thomas vor allen Dingen nach oben geguckt hat. An mir ist es ja hier mehr nach unten zu gucken und da hat mich auf jeden Fall überrascht, tatsächlich auch ein bisschen überrascht, dass Eintracht Braunschweig die Siegesserie fortgesetzt hat. Die hatten das erste Spiel gegen Kiel gewonnen, dann auch gegen Magdeburg gewonnen und da hatte ich natürlich darauf gehofft, dass denen das nicht so gelingt. Ist natürlich dann von unten mehr Druck gekommen, umso wichtiger für Schalke dann das direkte Duell gegen die Braunschweiger zu gewinnen. Reden wir ja wahrscheinlich dann gleich noch drüber, aber für mich war Braunschweig so die Überraschung der ersten zwei Spieltage, bevor dann das Spiel gegen uns stattgefunden hat.
Und da sieht man nämlich auch, was der Unterschied ist zwischen echten Experten, die eben gar nichts überrascht, und zum Beispiel mir, weil ich ja noch nicht deutlich widersprochen habe, und ich glaube auch selber mal gesagt habe hier in den vergangenen Monaten, ja, die unteren beiden, Braunschweig und Osnabrück, die sind wohl weg. Das heißt, es geht nur um den Relegationsplatz. Ja, ich hätte es natürlich besser wissen müssen. Braunschweig jetzt wirklich wieder dran. Punkt gleich mit Rostock, 20 Punkte. Lautern dann 21. Der VfL Osnabrück, das hat sich bewahrheitet, die sind wirklich ein bisschen entfernt. 11 Punkte nur, also 9 Punkte schon Rückstand. Wenn ich mir das da unten so angucke, Torsten, wir werden gleich ja noch ausführlicher auf Schalke 04 blicken. Aber wo würdest du den Cut machen? Welche Teams, glaubst du, können da unten nicht mehr reinrutschen? Wir haben Wiesbaden mit 26 Punkten härter, mit 26, dann irgendwann Nürnberg mit 28. Jetzt traue ich mich gar nicht mehr, Teams rauszurechnen aus dem Abstiegskampf nach meinem Braunschweig-Debakel.
Also ich würde mich da auch gar nicht festlegen wollen, weil das sehen wir ja jetzt tatsächlich. Du verlierst zwei Spiele und dann gibt es so einen Club wie Braunschweig, die gewinnen und dann ist das ratzfatz aufgebraucht. Also ich fühle mich da in keinster Weise sicher, was mein Club angeht. Wir sind natürlich erst recht nicht weit weg. Wir haben jetzt drei Punkte Vorsprung vor diesen Abstiegsringen. Ich gucke auch eher tatsächlich nach unten als nach oben. Also ich gucke da auf keine Grenze, sondern von Spiel zu Spiel. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es hier auch einen Rasenschwein? Ich glaube nicht, aber den wollte ich mal raushauen.
Okay, ja, sehr stark. Und wo können wir oben den Cut machen, Thomas? Offenbar ist es ja hier eine oben- und eine unten-Trennung. Das hatte ich vorher so gar nicht so drüber nachgedacht. St. Pauli als einziges Team, alle drei Spiele bisher in der Rückrunde gewonnen. Deswegen jetzt schon 42 Punkte. Der HSV 37, Kiel 36, Fürth 35. Und dann kommen Düsseldorf, Hannover und Paderborn, die alle 31 Punkte haben. Was glaubst du, wo müssen wir da den Cut machen? Wer kann da oben noch rein rucken?
Ich glaube, gedanklich bei Düsseldorf, auch wenn es ja, wie du gerade gesagt hast, punktemäßig eine Ebene ist. Den traue ich dann nicht. Trotzdem mehr zu noch im Laufe der Saison. Aber ehrlich gesagt auch nur als, wie soll ich sagen, edel Joker dann irgendwie, vielleicht wenn es wirklich besonders, besonders gut läuft. Und irgendeine Pokaleuphorie vielleicht auch noch, die in Sphären treibt, wo man sie jetzt vielleicht nicht erwarten kann. Ansonsten glaube ich, ist bei Kiel der Cut. Das sind dann die Mannschaften, die es unter sich ausmachen werden.
Also wirklich die ersten drei. Auch Fürth war da nicht mehr reingedrückt.
Ja, Entschuldigung, dann habe ich es.
Also bei Fürth ist der Cut, genau. Okay, aber du erwartest keinen Lauf. Ich meine, gut, Hannover, die haben jetzt irgendwie ihren Linksverteidiger noch verloren, Derrick Köhne ist jetzt noch nach Istanbul gewechselt, wie Thomas Leite das wo so fand. Na, er hat ihm nette Worte hinterhergeschickt. Paderborn, die ja schon manchmal so einen Lauf gestartet haben und ja vielleicht auch so einen Trainer haben, der es manchmal hinkriegen kann. Also das würde dich überraschen, wenn das passiert. Können wir dich darauf festnageln, Thomas?
Da kannst du mich dann später darauf festnageln, wenn einer von denen unter die ersten drei kommt. Das wäre eine Überraschung, für mich zumindest.
Okay, also dann lasst uns mal näher auf eure beiden Teams blicken. Und wir beginnen mit dem HSV, Thomas. Und da hast du dich geärgert über etwas, was ich gesagt habe in der Hinrundenbilanz. Denn ich habe gesagt, na ja, graduell ist ja der Kader immer schlechter geworden beim HSV. Und deswegen kann man vielleicht auch nicht erwarten, aufzusteigen. Warum war ich mit der Aussage daneben gelegen?
Ach, geärgert ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel. Ich habe mir nur gedacht, vielleicht schreibe ich dir einfach eine freundliche Mail und ich hoffe, die war auch dann im Endeffekt freundlich. Und da ging es eher so um die Tonalität des ganzen Gesprächs über den HSV. Eine zentrale Prämisse der Beurteilung und auch der Nachsicht mit den schwankenden Leistungen war ja irgendwie, dass es hieß, der HSV hat Jahr für Jahr weniger Geld zur Verfügung. Und das stimmt einfach nachweislich nicht. Also der HSV hat seinen Etat zu dieser Saison nochmal etwas erhöht auf ca. 24 bis 26 Millionen Euro Etat. Das ist Liga-Spitze. Die Zahlen schwanken, glaube ich, immer so ein bisschen, weil da vielleicht mal Boni reingerechnet werden mögliche bei einem Aufstieg und mal nicht. Das weiß ich jetzt so genau nicht. Man wird auch in der nächsten Saison das Niveau halten können, selbst wenn es mit dem Aufstieg nicht klappt. Und dieses Niveau ist auch höher als bei der Konkurrenz. Also St. Pauli z.B. hat, mein Infos zufolge, ein Drittel weniger an Etat. Und das ist in der 2. Liga einfach eine ganze, ganze Menge. Und diese Prämisse muss man, glaube ich, immer mitdenken, wenn man auch die Leistungen des HSV beurteilt und analysiert.
Ja, ja, total erstaunlich, dass ich dieses Feedback nur einmal bekommen habe. Denn ich weiß nicht, ob die HSV-Fans mich aufgegeben haben, aber in der Vergangenheit, gerade zu HSV-Sequenzen, gab es sehr, sehr viel Rückbildung. Vielleicht waren sie auch einfach nur dankbar, dass jetzt die Winterpause gekommen ist, in die man irgendwie so reingeschlittert ist. Aber wo würdest du denn sagen, liegen dann die Stärken im Kader, auch so gerade im Vergleich zum Rest der Liga? Weil das war etwas, da kenne ich mich dann halt wahrscheinlich zu schlecht aus, einfach mit den Spielern, die da gewechselt sind zum HSV. Wenn ich auf den Kader sehe, dann ist da für mich das Label 2. Liga drauf. Und dann kann man zwar aufsteigen, aber man muss es halt nicht.
Also grundsätzlich bin ich der Meinung, ich habe gerade so die finanziellen Rahmenbedingungen skizziert und ich bin auch der Meinung – und das bin nicht nur ich, also das höre ich tatsächlich sehr oft und auch von vielen Leuten, die wirklich Ahnung haben – die finanziellen Mittel wurden auch gar nicht so doof eingesetzt. Also die haben, finde ich, einen sehr guten, ausbalancierten Kader in der Spitze und in der Breite. Und wenn du jetzt konkret nach den Zugängen fragst, also gerade die bringen auch, finde ich, eine gewisse Qualität mit, zumindest auf dem Papier. Also du hast einen Hacika Dunic geholt, der vor, glaube ich, zwei, drei Jahren noch in Europa gespielt hat für die Innenverteidigung. Ein Fander Bremt, der, finde ich, relativ zweifelsfrei der beste Rechtsverteidiger der zweiten Liga ist. Wirklich eine absolute Maschine, physisch, vom Tempo her eigentlich überqualifiziert. Und in Feray einen Achter, der sich dann noch – da kommen wir gleich zum Thema Breite – auch gleich mit, der sich da mit Benisch und Reis um zwei Plätze abstrampelt und trotzdem allerhöchste Qualität hat in dieser Liga. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass in der Startformation des HSV schon fünf, sechs, sieben Spieler jetzt schon sind, die eigentlich Erstliga-Qualität haben. Also ich kann da keine Misswirtschaft erkennen, tatsächlich bei der Zusammenstellung des Kaders zumindest. Das heißt natürlich nichts für den sportlichen Ertrag, aber das muss man in Hamburg ja nicht groß erzählen.
Ja absolut, da werden wir dann gleich mal draufkommen. Aber da würde mich mal die Perspektive von Torsten erinnern, weil du – interessierend würde mich diese Perspektive – und zwar, weil du ja logischerweise jetzt erneuter Abstieg usw. und da hat sich ja auch der Kader stark gewandelt. Wenn du jetzt mal, jetzt ja auch mit der Erfahrung einer Hinserie, 2. Liga, die Kader von Schalke und HSV nebeneinander legst, würdest du da auch sagen, der HSV hat da die Nase vorn?
Absolut, vor allen Dingen auch den gewachseneren Kader. Ja, also das ist ja jetzt ein Kader, der halt dann nach und nach ausgebaut wurde, während bei Schalke der Umbruch vom Umbruch vom Umbruch folgt und immer wieder neu angefangen wird, weil bei Auf- und Abstieg allein schon durch die Budget-Problematik da halt immer Bedarf besteht, da wieder Spieler zu verkaufen, die dann zu teuer sind, Spieler zu holen, die man dann eben wieder auffüllen muss und so. Das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Situation. Und ich finde auch, dass Hamburg, also vom Kader her, würde ich sagen, in dieser Liga ja schon, ich weiß nicht, ob sie wirklich ganz oben stehen, aber völlig berechtigt unter diesen ersten drei Händen da stehen, also da passt schon der Kader und die Tabellenplatzierung absolut zusammen, würde ich auch so sagen.
Da würde ich fast widersprechen, weil ich die ganz, ganz oben sehen würde, zumindest von der reinen Kaderqualität und da würde mich interessieren, wen du noch auf einem ähnlichen Niveau verorten würdest.
Naja, ich finde halt, dass St. Pauli halt genauso dieses Eingespielte mitbringt. Die haben sich halt auch über eine ganze Weile hin aufgebaut und wurden halt immer stärker. Und das mache ich dann jetzt nicht an den einzelnen Namen vielleicht fest, sondern eher an dieser Kontinuität, mit der so ein Kader dann halt aufgebaut wird, wo man dann sieht, ok, der passt, der passt nicht, dann baut man hier mal wieder einen anderen ein und so. Beide Clubs haben jetzt halt die Zeit gehabt. Gut, man will die nicht unbedingt haben, man will natürlich schnell aufsteigen, aber auch der HSV hat die Zeit jetzt eben gehabt in dieser Liga und hat peu à peu sich den Kader immer wieder neu puzzleteilmäßig zusammengestellt. Wir haben jetzt auch den Trainer eine Weile schon, was natürlich auch darauf einzahlt, Kontinuität mit sich zu bringen und einen Kader zusammenzubauen, der dann irgendwie passt. Auch wenn der Trainer dann schon mal in der Kritik spielt, aber eher ob seines Spielstils und nicht ob der Ceiling, die der Kader hat, würde ich mal sagen. Zumindest aus meiner Sicht ist das so. Das zusammengestellt passt da schon. Wir müssen es halt auf den Feld bringen.
Ja, aber da sind wir ja dann beim springenden Punkt. Also wenn der Kader so gut ist – und ich erkenne das ja völlig an, also da lag ich halt dann einfach daneben in meiner Einschätzung – warum ist der HSV dann nicht an der Stelle, zumindest an der St. Pauli ist? Also mit einem Abstand zum Tabellen 2. Es ist ja gerade eher so, dass man jetzt eben schon wieder Punkte gelassen hat. Ein historisches 3 zu 4 zu Hause gegen den KSC, wo man sehr früh 0 zu 2 zurücklegt, dann sogar zurückkommt, es dann schafft, in die zweite Hälfte genauso schlecht zu starten, wie in die zweite Hälfte, wieder ausgleicht und dann aber dennoch noch das 3 zu 4 kassiert. Da platzt einem doch der Schädel.
Ja, geht so, weil man sich tatsächlich genau an solche Spiele gewöhnt hat, finde ich, seit Tim Walter da ist. Also letztendlich lässt sich seine Amtszeit – und er hat wirklich sehr viel Gutes bewirkt und auch tatsächlich einige Spieler davor entwickelt – das möchte ich gar nicht bestreiten. Aber ich finde, seine ganze Amtszeit ist eigentlich dieses KSC-Spiel. Und zwar im folgenden Sinne, dass das immer wieder ausrutscher passiert, man arbeitet sich zurück, man kämpft sich zurück in einzelnen Spielen, aber auch in Phasen über die Saison hinweg. Aber diese absolute Kontinuität, diese Schärfe einer Spitzenmannschaft, diese Balance und Stabilität, wie sie St. Pauli hat, wie sie Fabian Hürzeler einfach gar nicht mal über so einen langen Zeitraum entwickelt hat, sondern eben seit Anfang, ja, seit exakt einem Jahr, plus einen Monat, das ist einfach Tim Walter. Trotz bester Möglichkeiten muss man einfach jetzt bis Stand Februar 2024 feststellen, ist es einfach so nicht gelungen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich das Problem, dass der HSV auf einem möglichen Aufstiegsweg haben wird, weil du das einfach brauchst, um letztendlich unter den ersten Zwei zu landen.
Aber ist das jetzt immer noch so wie früher, dass es halt der Walterball ist und man läuft eben einfach sehenden Auges, weil man so offensiv spielt, immer wieder ins offene Messer? Weil zum Beispiel, Torsten, du hast ja den HSV auch erleben müssen, jetzt aus deiner Sicht, nämlich zum Auftakt in die Rückrunde. Und so ein 2 zu 0 auf Schalke, also jetzt aus Sicht des HSV, 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Ich hab das Spiel damals nur so mit einer halben Pupille verfolgen können. Aber das sah mir jetzt eigentlich relativ solide aus. Oder übersehe ich da gerade ganz viele Konter, die Schalke fahren konnten?
Ich wollte gerade schon dazwischen schreien. Ich wollte schon sagen, ja klar, die spielen gegen Kiel so, ne, rennen alle nach vorne und fangen sich dann noch die Dinger. Gegen uns haben die plötzlich alle vorm eigenen Strafraum gestanden und haben da echt ganz patent verteidigt, ne. Gut, kann man auch anhand der Qualität festmachen, die Schalke dann vielleicht nicht so auf den Rasen gebracht hat, wie es hätte sein müssen, aber eigentlich ist das Spiel schon in die richtige Richtung gelaufen und da hat Hamburg das gut gemacht. Also, die standen schon massiert da hinten und das ist das, was ich jetzt gesehen habe. Aber natürlich sehe ich die Zusammenfassung des HSVs und bin dann auch immer wieder entsetzt, wie das dann, ja, wie das dann doch so auskommt, dass so eine Mannschaft, die vorne so ein Power hat, da irgendwie, dass dir halt die Balance fehlt irgendwo, ja, ist schon so.
Und gab es da nicht den Versuch, Thomas, jetzt auch über die Winterpause hinweg, das eben zu stabilisieren? Ich meine, ich hätte da Zitate gelesen von Tim Walter, so ähnlich wie Identisic bei Dortmund weniger sexy, mehr erfolgreich, nur halt in der HSV-Variante.
Das hat er vor der Saison gesagt, also exakt dieses Zitat. Aber es war in der Tat so, dass in der Winterpause, kurz vor Weihnachten, haben sich da alle zusammengesetzt. Sportdirektor Costa, Sportvorstand Boll, Tim Walter. Und da ging es offenkundig auch ein wenig zumindest darüber, ob man mit ihm weitermacht. Mir war eigentlich immer relativ klar, dass es weitergehen wird. Aber ihm wurde ganz klar nahegelegt, dass er jetzt für mehr Stabilität und Balance sorgen muss. Und tatsächlich in dem Spiel gegen Schalke war das zu besichtigen. Weil du auch vorher konkret danach gefragt hast, so dieses wilde Positionsspiel und so weiter des Walter-Balls. Das ist jetzt schon auch generell konservativer. Aber was dieser Mannschaft nichts ist, und es hat man einfach gegen den KSC bei diesem wilden Spiel gesehen, ist diese defensive Mentalität und dieser Grundgedanke, stabil zu sein. Ich zweifel mittlerweile ganz stark daran, dass Tim Walter jemals der Trainer sein kann, der den Spielern das in individuellen Situationen über 90 Minuten hinweg und über eine Saison hinweg vermitteln kann. Weil es einfach seiner grundsätzlichen Herangehensweise und Identität und seinen Überlegungen von Fußball widerspricht. Und er will ja eigentlich gar nicht so spielen lassen. Wer ihn kennt, der weiß, eigentlich möchte Tim Walter nicht so ein Spiel wie auf Schalke sehen. Das widerstrebt dem. Er macht es, weil es von ihm verlangt wird. Aber ob das dann wirklich über die ganze Saison hinweg funktioniert oder ob man dann immer wieder ein alter Muster verfällt, wie es immer wieder zu besichtigen ist, ist halt die andere Frage.
Sorry, deine Sätze, alles gut. Aber sind wir uns einig, dass die Fans von 17 anderen Clubs sich wünschen, einen Trainer zu haben, der so offensiv denkt und der so einen Fußball auf die Tapete kriegen kann? Weil das Übliche ist ja, dass Trainer zu Clubs kommen und sagen, wir wollen jetzt mal defensiv stabil stehen und damit fangen wir mal an. Und dann versuchen die alles, das zu tun, stellen sich dann da rein. Und vielen gelingt das auch bis dahin. Aber das Offensivspiel darauf zu kreieren, darauf aufzubauen, Offensivspiel hinzubekommen, das kriegen ja die wenigsten auf die Kette. Also es wird besser, es gibt jetzt schon eine Reihe von Clubs, ich würde jetzt auch mal Magdeburg nehmen, die mit ihrem Trainer auch ein gutes Offensivspiel kreieren können und auch andere Probleme haben. Aber so dieses Übliche ist ja tatsächlich, man entlässt einen Trainer, weil es gerade nicht läuft, der nächste Trainer muss erstmal Stabilität reinbringen und redet dann davon, dass man immer erstmal sicher stehen muss und kämpfen muss und so was alles. Und dann sitzen da alle Fans und denken, wir wollen aber Fußball sehen und wollen ganz gerne ein gutes Offensivspiel sehen und wollen, dass unsere Mannschaft Tore schießt. Und in Hamburg erzählen Sie jetzt, okay, das ist genau das Falsche und man will das andere haben. Sind wir uns da einig?
Ja, es können natürlich, wenn man das zweieinhalb Jahre sieht, das sage ich jetzt auch mehr aus der Perspektive eines neutralen Beobachters, können da gewisse Ermüdungserscheinungen auch irgendwie eintreten, weil diese wilden Spiele, die können ja dann irgendwann auch eintönig werden. Und ich, wir haben vorhin darüber geredet, dass ich Trikots einer italienischen Fußballmannschaft hier in dem Raum hängen habe, in dem ich so spreche. Also ich kann auch sehr gut mich mit anderen Fußballphilosophien arrangieren und muss sagen, am Ende des Tages sollte alles zielführend sein. Und ich finde, was Fabian Hürzler eben mit St. Pauli hinbekommt, ist ja nichtsdestotrotz Attraktivität, aber die haben auch, die schämen sich nicht dafür, wenn sie auch einfach mal so ein 2-1 dann wegverteidigen und ja, einfach seriöse Ergebnis-Fußball spielen. Und der kann natürlich jeder seine eigenen Präferenzen haben. Was sieht er lieber? Was sieht er auch über zweieinhalb Jahre oder drei Jahre oder eben über eine ganze Saison lieber? Ich bin aber nur relativ klar in meiner Ansicht, dass eins zielführender sein dürfte als das andere.
Aber wenn jetzt der HSV nicht mehr ganz so offen steht gegen den Ball und auch nicht mehr ganz so riskant spielt und dann dennoch so ein Spiel wie eben gegen den KSC passiert, wo man zu Hause vier Gegentore kassiert, nachdem man zweimal einen Rückstand egalisieren konnte, kann dann nicht vielleicht dann doch die Kaderqualität in der Verteidigung nicht gut genug sein? Also in der letzten Saison haben an dieser Stelle Gäste dann oft noch den Namen Mario Vuskovic fallen lassen, der ja aus inzwischen gut bekannten Gründen nicht dabei sein kann. Würdest du das noch zählen lassen für diese Saison?
Für diese Saison definitiv nicht mehr. Also da hat man ja tatsächlich jetzt mehrere Transferperioden gehabt, um darauf zu reagieren. Was eher ins Konter schlägt, ist natürlich, dass Sebastian Schoenlau, also damals eben der Counterpart zu Mario Vuskovic ebenfalls fehlt. Also die haben sich wirklich hervorragend ergänzt. Vuskovic hat so ein bisschen Schoenlaus Temposchwächen kompensiert und andersrum natürlich Schoenlau Vuskovic's Unerfahrenheit in manchen Situationen, hat da eine gewisse Ruhe auch ausgestrahlt. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es dann letztendlich auch die Aufgabe eines jeden Zweitligatrainers, und das sage ich jetzt ganz pauschal, mit den vorhandenen Bordmitteln den bestmöglichen Fußball zu kreieren. Und wir haben gerade schon festgestellt, dass die vorhandenen Bordmittel beim HSV nichtsdestotrotz wirklich nicht schlecht sind, sondern wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Und habe ich vorher schon mal angedeutet, also ich bin sozusagen Nordreporter und kümmere mich um allerhand Clubs hier, die es gibt, und ich nutze tatsächlich jedes Gespräch um mit irgendwem, also fiktiver Termin in Bremen oder so, dann rede ich auch noch 10 Minuten über den HSV, weil ich diese Puzzleteile irgendwie eines Tages mal zusammenlegen will und die Erklärungen liefern die ultimative, warum dieser Club nicht in die Gänge kommt. Bitte liefer sie hier in Rasenfunk. Dann werde ich ein reicher Mann. Und die Meinungen sind da wirklich einhellig, dass diese Mannschaft underperformt. Dass diese Mannschaft einfach insgesamt, was den Output angeht, underperformt. Da bin ich mir eben nicht sicher, ob man dann langfristig, wenn man jetzt – Herr Hacika Dunic zum Beispiel erwähnt, der ja eigentlich geholt wurde, um neben Schonlautern zu spielen – wenn dann auch die Spieler underperformen, ob das dann gerade bei den Defensivspielern, denen das relativ häufig wiederfährt, ob es dann ausschließlich denen anzulasten ist, zumal genau dieser Hacika Dunic vor der Saison zitiert würde, so sollen wir Fußball spielen. Also er hat sich wirklich über die Herangehensweise, die war für den völlig neu, er hat sich sehr, sehr gewundert, wie das Positionsspiel damals einstudiert wurde und wo er dann tatsächlich in letzter Linie zu stehen hatte.
Also ich habe immer noch viele Fragezeichen, aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, die haben dann viele, die sich mit dem HSV beschäftigen. Wenn wir mal auf Personalien blicken, wir müssen jetzt nicht über Steffen Baumgart spekulieren, ich verstehe jetzt aber besser, warum diese Spekulation so laut war, dass sogar ich sie mitbekommen habe. Aber wenn wir einfach mal drei Namen nennen, Marcel Jansen, Jonas Beuth und Tim Walter. Marcel Jansen, schon nicht mehr als Präsident aktiv. Ich weiß nicht, ob es sich lohnt, da noch ein paar Worte zu verlieren, aber auch die anderen beiden. Wer glaubst du, wird am Ende dieser Saison dann noch da sein? Und in welchem Verhältnis steht denn eigentlich diese drei Konstellationen zueinander? Oder gibt es da vielleicht gar kein Verhältnis zwischen Beuth und Tim Walter? Definitiv, würde ich sagen.
Die haben ein sehr gutes Verhältnis. Ich würde fast sagen, die haben das beste Verhältnis, das ich jemals so, zumindest in meiner aktiven Zeit, so mitbekommen habe zwischen Sportchef und Trainer.
Vergiss nicht Markus Distow, der mit Horst H. Schnitzel gebraten hat. Das war auch sehr eng.
Ja, das war vor meiner Zeit. Zumindest als sozusagen HSV-Reporter. Die haben ein sehr, sehr gutes und enges Verhältnis. Nichtsdestotrotz ist Jonas Boldt profi genug, dass er, wenn er wirklich, ich finde, man hätte zu dem Entschluss eigentlich schon im Winter kommen können, also vor der Winterpause, wenn er wirklich keine Aussicht mehr sieht, mit diesem Trainer den Aufstieg zu schaffen, dann muss er auch den Trainer wechseln und das wird er dann auch tun, weil es ja sein persönlich fünfter Nicht-Aufstieg dann auch schon wäre. Und das jedes Mal entgegen sämtlicher mathematischer Wahrscheinlichkeiten, das wäre dann mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit auch sein Ende beim HSV. Das wäre ja dann tatsächlich auch einfach nicht mehr seriös vermittelbar, wenn er dann in ein siebtes Jahr, jetzt ich komme da mit den Zahlen immer ganz durcheinander, so groß sind sie mittlerweile angewachsen. Ja, doch, das wäre dann glaube ich sein siebtes Jahr, nächste Saison. Das wäre halt einfach eine, also gerade für Hamburger Verhältnisse, das wäre ja eine Ära, ohne dass man je halt dann eben diesen sportlichen Ertrag einfahren konnte, für den man ja letztendlich dann doch als Sportvorstand da ist.
Und ist das Wegbrechen von Marcel Jansen vom HSV noch ein größeres Thema? Also es kam ja jetzt nicht so komplett überraschend und so weiter, und es gab mehrere Unstimmigkeiten. Und wir sprechen ja hier einmal vom Präsidenten, und das andere ist ja quasi die ausgegliederte Abteilung, die nur Fußball spielt.
Nee, also da war schon, was man so mitbekommt, bereits länger da irgendwie isoliert auch. Und hat auf das Tagesgeschäft keinen nennenswerten Einfluss. Also als Figur auch schon länger nicht mehr irgendwie so richtig, richtig irgendwie präsent da in der AG zumindest.
Und wie würdest du beschreiben, ist dann jetzt aktuell die Stimmung im HSV-Umfeld? Das scheint mir eine ziemlich verworrene Situation sein, in der man irgendwie wahrscheinlich aus fällen Sicht hofft, dass es halt einfach aus irgendeinem Grund gut geht. Man könnte es sich dann wahrscheinlich genauso wenig erklären, wie man sich nicht erklären konnte, warum es jetzt nicht gut gegangen ist die letzten Jahre. Aber ich sehe hier irgendwie keine klare Linie für den HSV.
Welches Umfeld meinst du dann konkret? Also tatsächlich eher rund um die Geschäftsstelle oder die Fans?
Also erstmal die Fans, aber die Geschäftsstelle interessiert mich natürlich auch.
Das Beide ist ein bisschen diffus. Also tatsächlich kann man da jetzt finde ich schon so ein bisschen so eine Spaltung in Anführungszeichen vernehmen, dass das doch die Walter-Gegner und jene, die dem Trainer nicht mehr den Aufstieg zutrauen, die werden mehr. Es gibt aber auch ganz überzeugte und gläubige Walter-Jahner, die mit ihm – so habe ich zumindest manchmal den Eindruck – auch gut und gerne einen weiteren Nicht-Aufstieg in Kauf nehmen würden, einfach weil sie ihn als Persönlichkeit irgendwie im Volkspark behalten wollen. Das ist alles doch sehr diffus.
Und wie ist es dann auf der Geschäftsstelle?
Ja, also wie ich gerade schon so ein bisschen angedeutet habe, gibt es da doch ein sehr großes Zutrauen in den Trainer. Aber nichtsdestotrotz war er noch nie so auf der Kippe gestanden, wie jetzt in den vergangenen Wochen. Und gerade dieses KSC-Spiel hat dann schon irgendwie vielen auf den Magen geschlagen und dann doch so ein bisschen daran zweifeln lassen, dass man eben diese Entscheidung so getroffen hat, die man getroffen hat. Ich würde aber nochmal Wert darauf legen auf das Wort ein bisschen. Also da ist jetzt noch keine Fatalität oder so eingekehrt.
Damit wir auch nochmal kurz fragen, ist das denn denkbar, dass dann so ein Feuer, also so ein Aufstiegsfeuerwehrmann noch eingesetzt wird? Oder denkst du, dass die Saison auf jeden Fall mit Tim Walter zu Ende geführt werden wird von Volt?
Also generell ist es bei Tim Walter halt immer wieder so, dass er – wir haben ja gerade so über das KSC-Spiel geredet – als Sinnbild seiner Amtszeit. Also man hat dann immer wieder rechtzeitig noch ein Argument mit ihm weiterzumachen. So, jetzt haben wir aber vorhin festgestellt, dass langsam die Argumente für sämtliche Beteiligten langsam ausgehen. Und ich denke schon, wenn es jetzt nochmal eine kleine Schwächephase gibt und genug Zeit ist zu reagieren, dann wird man das tun. Und auch tun müssen. Und damit sage ich gar nicht, dass Tim Walter nicht aufsteigen kann. Ich persönlich glaube nicht unbedingt mehr daran, weil ich finde, man hat jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre wirklich sehr gut gesehen, wofür dieser Trainer oder wozu dieser Trainer in der Lage ist und wozu vielleicht er nicht. Er war ein hervorragender Entwicklungsarbeiter. Er hat diese Mannschaft auch mitentwickelt. Viele Spiele besser gemacht. Aber ich und viele andere übrigens glauben nicht, dass das der Trainer sein kann, der so einen Aufstieg organisiert, und zwar seriös zu Ende organisiert. Und deswegen glaube ich, um dann nochmal anzuknüpfen, dass durchaus das Thema Steffen Baumgart – Max hat es ja gerade erwähnt – dass es einfach nochmal ein Thema werden wird oder werden kann zumindest. Es ist ja wirklich auch einfach – es ist ja eigentlich ein unfassbarer Wink des Schicksals, dass wirklich der vermeintlich perfekte – mir fallen zumindest wenige Gegenargumente ein – dass der vermeintlich perfekte Ersatzkandidat auf dem Markt ist und immer wieder sagt, er hat übrigens wieder Lust zu arbeiten. Und seit Kindestagen HSV-Fern ist er auch. Also der würde das machen. Da möchte ich mich jetzt nicht so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber es gibt da auch so paar Schwingungen, die zu vernehmen sind aus dieser Richtung. Wenn Jonas Bold ihn anrufe, ist nicht davon auszugehen, dass Steffen Baumgart da jetzt nicht hingeht oder so.
Aber der versteht sich doch nicht so gut mit Tim Walter. Das ist ja eine einzige Dokusopie. Aber gut, vielen Dank Thomas. Jetzt verstehe ich ein bisschen besser, warum beim HSV die Stimmung trotz eines zweiten Platzes und der zweitbesten Offensive der Liga dann eben doch so kritisch ist. Also nach dem KSC-Spiel, das habe ich schon auch verstanden. Blind bin ich ja auch nicht, aber immerhin dann 2 zu 1 zum Beispiel bei Hertha gewonnen. Und da eben auch wieder die individuelle Qualität, die du zu Recht hervorgehoben hast, die hat man ja da auch wieder gesehen, fand ich vor allem. Das 2 zu 1 war ja wirklich von Varei. Also dieser erste Kontakt, der war richtig schön. Und die Flanke, die war dann auch ganz wunderbar.
Das ist ein super Fußballer, ja. Die zwei Siege muss man vielleicht noch ganz kurz erwähnen. Das war ja eben gegen Schalke und Hertha jetzt in dem Jahr. Und das sind ja tatsächlich, werden wir auch gleich nochmal wahrscheinlich ein bisschen detaillierter besprechen, ja nicht, obwohl die Namen groß sind, ja nicht tatsächlich die schwierigsten Gegner in dieser Liga gewesen. Das gehört, glaube ich, schon auch zur Wahrheit dazu. Und ich glaube, das wissen die Beteiligten auch, wenn sie dann auch noch auf die Waage zusätzlich dieses KSC-Spiel legen.
Ja, guter Punkt. Und trotzdem habe ich mich eben jetzt schon mehrfach gefragt, Torsten, was du dir eigentlich denkst, wenn wir hier über den HSV sprechen, der natürlich in seiner ganzen HSV-igkeit Geschichte um Geschichte geschrieben hat in jeder Zweitliga-Saison. Und wir jetzt aber halt gleich über Schalke sprechen, die drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz haben. Die hat man wesentlich, weil man jetzt ein Spiel gegen Braunschweig gewinnen konnte, wo du ja schon gesagt hast, warum das eben so extrem wichtig war. Und wo ich auch schon aus dem Umfeld – und das wäre jetzt dann meine erste Frage – auch schon die Sorge gehört habe, oh Gott, rauschen die durch, geht es runter in die dritte Liga. Ist das Panik oder wie viel Substanz sind an solchen Gedanken dran, deiner Meinung nach?
Ich meine, dass das eine reale Gefahr darstellt, ist da irgendwie ganz klar. Und wenn man irgendwie frohen Mutes in die Rückrunde startet und dann so ein Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern hinlegt, wo man so abgefieselt wird, wo man irgendwie den Eindruck macht, dass man überhaupt nicht verstanden hat, worum es geht, dann ist diese Gefahr auf jeden Fall da. Und real und jeder, der da Angst vor hat, dessen Ängste sind, durchaus nachzuvollziehen, ganz klar.
Und wie ist deine Seelenlage dahingehend?
Meine Seelenlage ist auch nicht viel anders. Ich habe natürlich auch Bedenken. Ich gucke natürlich auch nur nach unten und gucke bei jedem Spiel der anderen Clubs, die jetzt da unten stehen, sei es jetzt Rostock, Braunschweig, Oldenburg, bin ich froh und mutig, dass sie auch da unten bleiben werden.
Also Osnabrück, nicht Oldenburg.
Das ist so ein Klassiker bei mir. Das sage ich vielleicht noch dreimal falsch, sorry. Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Ich schaue da immer hin und bin immer froh, wenn die die Punkte nicht einfahren. Nichtsdestotrotz muss Schalke einfach besser Fußball spielen. Das war bislang echt eine ganz schlimme Saison. Und meine Angst ist genauso real wie die der anderen.
Wann war noch mal der Trainerwechsel? Der war nach dem siebten Spieltag. Da wurde Thomas Reiß entlassen.
Genau, dann war ein Spiel Kreuzer an der Seitenlinie.
Und danach kam Gerrard. Und warum hat sich unter ihm wenigstens etwas verbessert?
Ich glaube schon, dass sich etwas verbessert hat. Von der ganzen Spielstruktur her gab es Spiele, wo man gesehen hat, dass da etwas anderes entstehen soll. Wo man erkennen konnte, wie der Trainer Fußball spielen lassen möchte. Aber es gab immer wieder diese Rückfälle. Es gab immer wieder Probleme, dass die Spieler, die im Mittelfeld eingesetzt wurden, nicht gut harmoniert haben. Dieses ganze Abwehrkonstrukt hat nicht funktioniert. Wo man überhaupt sagen muss, dass diese Defensive, die große Achilles-Szene dieses Klubs und dieses ganzen Kaders ist. Wenn Schalke es irgendwie schaffen würde, sichere zu stehen und weniger Tore zu kassieren, die Offensive würde dann schon die Tore machen. Aber das Bedingt sich halt alles gegenseitig. Wenn man dann nach zehn Minuten nach der zweiten Flanke direkt einen Kopfball gegen Tor von einem Stürmer kassiert, der mal wieder frei im Strafraum stand, dann werden die vorne auch nicht mit Selbstvertrauen dadurch unterfüttert. Dann gerät das ganze Ding halt ins Wanken.
Also sprich hier, sprechen wir jetzt nicht über den besten Kader der Liga. Den Platz haben wir ja vergeben. Aber war das abzusehen, dass die Defensive die zweitschlechteste der 2. Liga ist? 41 Gegentreffer, nur Osnabrück oder Oldenburg, wie Insider es nennen, hat 42 Gegentreffer. War das abzusehen, dass das auch tatsächlich so ein Problem werden würde?
Es war zumindest mal zu befürchten, dass die Innenverteidigung, oder eigentlich ja doch die Innenverteidigung, so eine Art Sollbruchstelle da ist. Also irgendwie die Stelle, wo es knacken kann, wo es am ehesten knackt. Weil wenn man sich das mal anschaut, wen Schalke da verpflichtet hat, dann ist es halt so, dass mit Baumgartel jemand geholt wurde, der sehr lange vorher nicht ordentlich am Spielbetrieb teilgenommen hat, der aus seiner langen Krankheitsphase herauskam und danach kaum noch gespielt hat. Und mit Thomas Callas hat man Spieler geholt, der auch aussortiert war, der auch lange nicht gespielt hat. Marcian Kaminski ist mittlerweile alt, muss man sagen, wird nicht mehr schneller werden in seiner Karriere, ist bestimmt noch ein Spieler, der ein Auge hat, der viel mit seiner Erfahrung machen kann, aber der wird kein Gegner ablaufen. Und dann hat man als weitere Kandidatin in der Innenverteidigung Leo Greimel, der einen Kreuzbandriss hatte, der ganz raus war und gar nicht gespielt hat, und Ibrahima Sissé, der bestimmt talentiert ist, der auch in einem U-Turnier gezeigt hat, was er kann, aber der auf Männerniveau gar keine Erfahrung hat. Insofern hat man quasi keinen Innenverteidiger-Paar parat gehabt, wo man sagen könnte, die haben letzte Saison gut durchgespielt. Die waren irgendwie stabil und haben eine saisonlange Leistung gebracht. Das waren alles Leute, die mit Fragezeichen in den Kader gestellt wurden, wo man befürchten musste, dass das vielleicht nicht funktioniert. Dann hat sich direkt Leo Greimel wiederverletzt. Baumgartel kam nicht so richtig auf die Füße, also leistungsmäßig. Dann nahm das Unheil seinen Lauf. Mittlerweile ist Thomas Callas, der dann auch so aus dem Blauen gezogen wurde, der dann mit viel Hoffnung gezogen wurde. Der ist mittlerweile derjenige, über den man sich freut, dass er spielt. Der Beste ist da tatsächlich. Aber diese Innenverteidigung war von Beginn an so aufgebaut, dass man Bedenken haben konnte, sogar musste, würde ich sagen.
Das ist der Grund, warum man jetzt in Winter einen Rechtsverteidiger und einen Stürmer geholt hat, oder einen Linksaußen.
Ja, dramatisch. Genau, das fand ich auch sehr falsch. Es ist so, dass das ganze Defensivkonstrukt nicht nur an der Innenverteidigung liegt. Man hat im defensiven Mittelfeld mit Ron Schallenberg einen Spieler geholt, der vorher in Paderborn gut performt hat, der aber in Paderborn in einem System gespielt hat, wo er in einer Teil-Anne Doppel-Sechs war, und der auf Schalke das plötzlich alleine machen sollte. Egal, wie man daneben gestellt hat, das hat nicht so richtig harmoniert. Jetzt kann man sagen, so ein Spieler muss das irgendwie hinkriegen, ja, muss er vielleicht auch, aber es waren eben auch viele neue Spieler. Also Tempelmann ist gekommen, Schallenberg ist gekommen, eigentlich Paul Seguin ist gekommen, also dieses ganze Mittelfeld, dieses zentrale Mittelfeld, ist ja neu gekommen. Das kann gut gehen, das kann klappen, plötzlich verstehen die sie alle super und ergänzen sich auf den Platz. Das kann aber auch schiefgehen und das ist halt schiefgegangen. Also da fehlte so ein bisschen das Gerüst, wo man neue Spieler einbaut, das war nicht mehr so gegeben und das Neue harmonierte nicht so richtig. Und dass man jetzt in der Transferphase dann einen Rechtsverteidiger geholt hat und keinen Innenverteidiger und keinen defensiven Mittelfeldspieler, sondern weiter hofft, dass diejenigen, die da sind, das dann schon wuppen werden, fand ich persönlich ein bisschen dramatisch falsch, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, also natürlich kann man darüber sich unterhalten, dass die Rechtsverteidigerposition vielleicht noch die Position ist, die im Kader am dünnsten besetzt ist. Also wir haben da Cedric Brunner, der defensiv einen ordentlichen Part spielt, der gute Spiele gemacht hat, aber der nicht irgendwie von da hinten heraus ein Spiel mit antreibt. Das hat er in ganz wenigen, ganz wenigen Spielen mal gezeigt. Im Großen und Ganzen eher nicht der komplette Außenbahnrechtsverteidiger. Und wir haben Henning Matriziani, ein Spieler, der letzte Saison als U23-Spieler gute Spiele abgeliefert hat, überraschend gute Spiele abgeliefert hat, der weiß, was er kann und was er nicht kann, der ein großer Kämpfer vor dem Herrn ist, der aber jetzt auch in ein Loch gefallen ist. Ich hatte immer den Eindruck, der braucht dringend eine Pause. Der war derjenige, der immer spielen musste, weil ständig irgendwo einer ausgefallen ist. Dann hat er mal in der Innenverteidigung gespielt, dann hat er wieder auf rechts gespielt. Letzte Saison hat er auch mal links gespielt. Der ist überall und nirgends. Er kam aber in dieser Saison leistungsmäßig nicht auf die Füße. Jetzt ist die Idee, man holt sich einen Rechtsverteidiger, hat Hans-Hedrik Brunner vielleicht möglicherweise sogar für eine Innenverteidigung zur Verfügung, wenn man mal auf eine 3er-Abwehrkette wechseln würde. Aber der Rechtsverteidiger, der geholt wurde, der hat, wie alle anderen, auch die letzten Spiele nicht gespielt. Er ist auch nicht fit, war verletzt, ist nicht im Flow. Er wird hoffentlich überhaupt auch mal zu seiner Form finden, weil der ist jetzt nur für ein halbes Jahr ausgeliehen. Aber das ist halt so ein bisschen die Crocs. Man hat den Eindruck, man schaut nur danach oder hofft, dass man sich dann Spieler holen kann, die eigentlich ein höheres Niveau haben, die man nur aufgrund so einer Situation günstig kriegt. Oder man hat einfach so wenig Kohle, dass man einfach keine anderen Spieler verpflichten kann. Das kann ich nicht beurteilen tatsächlich.
Jetzt dachte ich nämlich, ich könnte da kurz Thomas einbinden zu Brandon Sopie, der eben von Atalanta gekommen ist. Aber zumindest in dieser Saison ist ja wirklich die Fallzahl der Spiele nicht so arg groß.
Jetzt sind wir ja ziemlich ergiebig durch den Kader gewandert. Ich kenne es aus Hamburg und von anderen Traditionsstandorten, dass es ja auch mystische Kräfte geben soll, dunkle Kräfte, die so einen Club und so ein ganzes Gebild nach unten ziehen. Manchmal auch so Druck genannt. Was ist, denkst du, Torsten, das für ein Faktor? Ich meine, Schalke macht ja jetzt, wenn man ehrlich ist, doch seit einer geraumen Zeit irgendwie so eine ziemlich destruktive Phase durch, würde ich sagen.
Absolut. Ja, und natürlich hat das viel auch mit Druck zu tun. Natürlich ist es so, dass wenn der Erfolg nicht da ist, auf Schalke natürlich, also die Hütte ist immer voll, dann werden die Leute unzufrieden. Dann gibt es die Reporter, die jeden Tag da sind, die nicht nur irgendwie alle drei Tage vorbeikommen. In der Bildzeitung gibt es jeden Tag die Geschichte über Schalke 04. Natürlich macht das Druck. Natürlich sind die Leute auch unzufrieden. Die sehen, dass ihr Verein immer weiter runtergeht und machen sich Sorgen, wie wir gerade schon gesagt haben. Das erzeugt natürlich Druck. Das habe ich gerade auch in meinem Text zum letzten Spiel beschrieben. Ich fand das sehr eindrücklich. Das Spiel gegen Braunschweig wurde abgepfiffen. In dem Moment, wo der Abpfiff ertönt ist, ist Derry Mörkin wirklich auf den Boden gegangen und konnte seine Emotionen kaum zurückhalten. Kenan Karaman hat auf der Bank gesessen, als ob man diese Bilder einsortieren könnte. Entweder in Abstieg, wo alle entsetzt sind, oder in Aufstieg, wo alle den Druck gelöst haben. Das konnte man gar nicht so richtig fassen. Aber das war mehr als ein normales Drei-Punktespiel. Das konnte man den Spielern anmerken, wie wichtig das war, diese drei Punkte einzufahren, diesen Abpfiff zu erleben, diese Führung über die Zeit gebracht zu haben. Simon Terodde ist mit seiner Jubelfaust in die Knie gegangen. Da hat man schon gemerkt, was dahinter steht. Das ist den Spielern durchaus klar. Aber es war auch zu sehen, dass das leben kann. Auch das Spiel gegen Braunschweig war nicht besonders gut.
Das ist ja dann doch grundsätzlich ein positives Signal, wie du das schilderst. Dass die Spieler sich in diese Aufgabe widmen und da auch wirklich mitfühlen. Wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel ins erste Abstiegsjahr zurückversetzt, da war ja vor allem eine große Neutralität der sportlichen Schande gegenüber zu vernehmen. Da siehst du schon einen klaren Unterschied zur Mannschaft von damals.
Ich bin, glaube ich, weiter von entfernt, Spielern von vornherein vorzuwerfen, dass sie sich nicht irgendwie engagieren würden. Ich glaube, das ist immer eine Sache, die kommt dann so ins Rollen. Wenn ich mich daran erinnere, wie damals der Abstieg aus der ersten Liga gelaufen ist zu der Corona-Zeit. Schalke wollte dann Fußball spielen. Dann ging es immer, zehn Minuten war das Spiel okay. Dann hat man wieder das Gegentor kassiert. Das war immer so dasselbe. Dann gab es immer wieder denselben Nackenschlag. Irgendwann ist das in eine Abwärtsspirale gerutscht, wo jeder bei dem ersten Gegentor schon gedacht hat, ach du Schande, genau das Gleiche wie immer. Dann gingen die Köpfe nach unten. Auch den Leuten damals will ich nicht vorhalten, dass sie nicht gewollt hätten. Aber es ist zum Glück jetzt auch schon eine Weile vorbei. Lass uns lieber über die Mannschaft reden. Ja, da bin ich ganz bei dir. Die erkennen das schon. Aber so ein Druck ist eben auch belastend. Ich bin mal froh, dass diese drei Punkte Vorsprung sind. Selbst wenn jetzt was schief geht, rutscht man nicht sofort wieder ganz unten rein. Jetzt kommt Kiel, die die letzten Spiele auch nicht gewonnen haben. Das ist so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung.
Aber würdest du sagen, du wolltest jetzt zwar nicht über die vergangenen Jahre sprechen, aber wenn ich mich jetzt mit dir austauschen kann, mit jemandem, der schon seit 2007 über Schalke 04 blockt, mit kürzeren Pausen. Aber du hast ja quasi immer wieder nicht nur Spiele gesehen, sondern sie dann auch noch textlich verarbeitet. Und Thomas wird das ja auch kennen, dass man dann nochmal ganz anders Dinge strukturiert. Und manchmal, wenn man durch alte Texte nochmal so quer liest, denkt man sich, ach ja, stimmt, das war ja damals auch schon. Ist das jetzt der klassische Schalke Druck, einfach nur angewandt auf die 2. Liga? Oder hat sich da vielleicht auch etwas verändert? Vielleicht sogar dahingehend, dass man ja Angst haben muss, wenn es jetzt in die 3. Liga gehen würde. Wir wollen es nicht hoffen. Aber dann steht man ja vor vielleicht noch existenzielleren Fragen, was man eigentlich nicht steigern kann. Aber ihr versteht mich, glaube ich, als beim Abstieg von der 1. Liga in die 2. Liga.
Ja, natürlich. Ja, natürlich. Also Abstieg ist – also Abstieg aus der 1. Liga. Aber vorher, die ganze Phase vorher, ja, wenn es halt darum geht, ob du dich jetzt für die Champions League qualifizierst oder nicht und du einen Trainer rausschmeißt, weil er jetzt gerade auf Platz 3 anstatt auf Platz 2 steht. Ja, das fühlte sich damals auch arg an. Ja, aber das ist jetzt natürlich eine ganz andere Nummer, weil jetzt geht es halt wirklich darum – also und dieser ganze Hintergrund. Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass Schalke nicht absteigen darf in die 3. Liga, sondern die müssen natürlich auch aufgrund der hohen Verbindlichkeiten und der finanziellen Nöte möglichst flott wieder ins obere Tabellendrittel kommen, um irgendwie an den TV-Keldern zu verdienen, um überhaupt sich wieder so zu steigern, dass man innerhalb der nächsten Jahre aufsteigt. Weil ganz ehrlich, mit diesen hohen Verbindlichkeiten kann man sich eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass Schalke jetzt drei, vier Jahre in der 2. Liga bleibt und dann irgendwie was aufgebaut bekommt in dieser Phase. Sondern dann geht es darum, alles irgendwie so zusammenzukehren, dass man überhaupt irgendwie überleben kann. Weil natürlich diese ganzen Verbindlichkeiten, die da in diesen Phasen aufgebaut wurden, wo Schalke in der Champions League gespielt haben, dieses ganze große Rad, was immer gedreht wurde, das hängt einem jetzt halt wie ein Mühlstein um den Hals. Das erdrückt Schalke 04. Das ist nicht möglich, mit solchen Problemen irgendwie da unten drin zu stehen, ohne wirklich eklatante Einschnitte zu machen, wenn es denn dann so bleiben würde. Insofern ist die große Hoffnung, dass es jetzt tatsächlich möglichst schnell wieder nach oben geht, dass es jetzt gerade so eine Phase war, wo es eben nicht funktioniert hat. Man hat sich jetzt wieder die neue Mannschaft zusammengestellt nach dem letzten Abstieg. Und ja, jetzt hat man den neuen Trainer und hofft darauf, dass der es halt hinkriegt, die Mannschaft zusammenzuführen und dann halt sportlichen Erfolg zu bringen. Das ist das, was zählt, der sportliche Erfolg. Und zwar auch nicht der langfristige, sondern durchaus auch der kurzfristige tatsächlich.
Vielleicht eine kleine Parallele zum HSV. Und hast du das Gefühl, du hast schon so ein bisschen beschrieben, was Karel Gerrads auf dem Feld gemacht hat, dass da durchaus eine gestabilisiert wurde. Man spielt ja jetzt ja auch mit Viererkette schon seit einer geraumen Zeit. Hast du denn das Gefühl, dass er es auch schafft, das Umfeld, man sagt immer so, mitzunehmen. Aber da gibt es ja durchaus bei Schalke mehr zu holen als bei anderen Teams. Also wenn alle zusammenstehen auf Schalke, dann ist man ja wirklich immer noch eine Macht.
Ja, das hat der Thomas Reis vorher auch gut geschafft. In dieser Abstiegssaison hat er es sehr gut hingekriegt, so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl zu kreieren. Die Fans haben sich eben auch, ich sag mal, verschworen und haben gesagt, okay, wir kämpfen gemeinsam gegen diesen Abstieg. Und da war ja auch dieses Gemeinschaftsgefühl die große Stärke von Schalke 04 tatsächlich. Hat halt natürlich am Ende nicht gereicht, wissen wir alle. Jetzt haben wir Karel Chiraz, der ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, schon angesehen. Und viele können, glaube ich, sich vorstellen, dass das ein Trainer ist, der hier Erfolg haben kann, der irgendwie auch, ja, sich dahinstellt und sagt, so, wir sind jetzt hier, wir sind jetzt hier Schalke. Und der steht auch dafür. Ich glaube schon, dass er vom Typ her da passend ist. Aber natürlich braucht der Mann Erfolg, so. Und das muss halt, das ist ja ganz normal. Also, das kann ja noch so ein guter Trainer sein, ja. Egal, wer da kommt. Und das kennen wir auf Schalke ja auch aus Erfahrung. Da können die größten Namen kommen. Wenn danach die Siege fehlen, dann sind die Leute halt irgendwann wieder durch. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch – also, was heißt wahrscheinlich? Das ist ja auch bei anderen Clubs nicht so. Nur bei uns geht es halt jetzt seit geraumer Zeit immer bergab. So. Und jetzt müssen wir halt mal drauf hoffen, dass es diesmal wieder andersrum geht, tatsächlich.
Also das ist die Trainersituation. Und was hat es zu bedeuten, dass Andre Hechelmann, der ehemalige Sportdirektor, jetzt technischer Direktor ist und dafür Max Wilmots neuer Sportdirektor ist, aber ja auch keinen Innenverteidiger geholt hat? Also sein erstes, das ganz, ganz kurzfristige Zeugnis, was man ihm ausstellen könnte, hätte schon mal gewisse Leerstellen, würde ich sagen.
Was hat das zu bedeuten? Das hat zu bedeuten, dass man sich jemand zweites dahin holen soll, der so ein bisschen jetzt ein Zwischending darstellt, zwischen dem technischen Direktor auf der einen Seite und der Vorstandsposition, die ja jetzt dadurch umgesetzt ist. Also, Max Wilmots ist ja jetzt als Kopf neu dazugekommen, nachdem Peter Knebel als Vorstand jetzt zurückgetreten ist, der zwar noch Vertrag hat, aber dessen Position jetzt nicht neu besetzt wurde. Und da hat man halt Mark Wilmots dazwischen geschaltet und ihm jetzt halt dann die Sportdirektor-Position gegeben. Und André Hechelmann ist halt jetzt der technische Direktor, der halt dann weiter im Hintergrund arbeitet, wo man sagen muss, man hatte schon das Gefühl, dass gerade diese Rolle im Vordergrund, also dieses nach Aussehen präsentieren und für den Verein sprechen, auch was war, was André Hechelmann irgendwie nicht so lag. Also das sah so aus, als würde er sich dabei unwohl fühlen. Kann sein, dass ich ihm jetzt unrecht damit tue. Aber das war schon so ein bisschen schwierig, was das angeht. Und ja, jetzt ist Mark Wilmotz da. Und ist jetzt halt natürlich eine Persönlichkeit, der jetzt da steht und dann auch spricht. Und wie die beiden jetzt natürlich harmonieren, da steckt halt keiner drin. Das ist halt so. Ich meine, Mark Wilmotz ist gekommen und hat gesagt, okay, wir müssen ein Team sein, wir müssen das zusammen machen. Hat aber auch schon in seinen Interviews klargemacht, dass er dann schon derjenige welcher ist, der dann das letzte Wort hat. Und wie gut sich das nachher ausbaldovert mit den beiden, das werden wir nachher dann an den Ergebnissen festmachen müssen. Und ja, das bleibt halt tatsächlich abzuwarten, weil dafür ist er natürlich noch viel zu frisch da.
Aber übersehe ich irgendwas? Oder war Mark Wilmots vorher noch nie Sportdirektor oder eben in so einer zwischengescheiterten Funktion? Weil ich habe hier nur Trainerstation von ihm. Natürlich auf Schalke, dann länger bei Belgien. Das haben wir alle mitbekommen. Und dann Elfenbeinküste und Iran. Da hat er dann irgendwann, weil sein Gehalt nicht gezahlt wurde, gekündigt. Aber er war ja doch eigentlich nur als Trainer unterwegs zuletzt.
Genau, er war als Trainer unterwegs. Er hat noch nicht so eine Funktion inne gehabt. Wobei er gesagt hat, dass er als Verbandstrainer in Belgien schon Aufgaben übernommen hat, die der Sache schon nahe kommen. Und dass er sich im Fußball befindet, schon seit geraumer Zeit, ist natürlich auch ganz klar. Ich will ihm das Wissen dazu nicht absprechen, dass er in der Position noch nicht gearbeitet hat. Ist so. Am Ende muss man sehen, was er zu bewegen weiß.
Aber ist er dann derjenige, der dann zum Beispiel auf Verträge verhandeln muss? Oder macht das dann jemand anders?
Das kann ich nicht beantworten, ob er das macht oder ob das von jemand anderem übernommen wird im Verein. Wie die Aufteilung da genau ist, kann ich nicht sagen.
Weil das jetzt von außen betrachtet, bei einem Verein, der so klamm ist wie Schalke 04, da aber auch noch so hohen Cashroll hat. Also die Einnahmen sind ja immer noch krass, die Schalke hat. Das ist Erstliganiveau immer noch. Also bei den letzten von der DFL veröffentlichten Zahlen, 2021, 2022, war man auf Rang 6 komplett deutschlandweit im Profifußball, was das Rohergebnis angeht. Nämlich fast 200 Millionen Euro. Es waren ein paar Transfers mit dabei. Das geht jetzt natürlich auch runter mit sinkendem TV-Geld. Aber ich will sagen, es wird viel Geld bewegt. Es geht aber auch wahnsinnig viel Geld raus, weil die Verbindlichkeiten bedient werden müssen. Aber da hätte ich jetzt gesagt, die Hauptkompetenz, die ein Sportdirektor haben muss, ist neben dem Blick natürlich für Talente und so. Das muss man können. Das Zweite ist, man muss sehr, sehr geschickt im Verhandeln von Verträgen sein.
Ja, würde ich mir auch so vorstellen. Genau, sehe ich auch so. Man muss vielleicht auch mal kreativ sein, weil Schalke ja jetzt seit einer Weile dann halt mit der Vorgehensweise, mit der man vorgegangen ist, eben nicht so erfolgreich war. Da muss man vielleicht auch mal andere Ideen mitbringen und einen neuen Hintergrund reinbringen. Eine gewisse Erfahrung wäre vielleicht auch nicht schlecht gewesen. Der Punkt ist, dass jetzt Mark Wilmots da ist und dem zumindest mal zugehalten werden kann, dass er Druck aushält. Also wenn man jetzt mal überlegt, wen holt man da rein, dann ist, glaube ich, ein Argument, dass jetzt jemand gekommen ist, der vermutlich eher druckresistent ist als jemand anderes Junges, für den Schalke dann wieder der nächste Schritt ist. Das wäre dann ja so die andere Variante. Die andere Variante wäre, man holt sich irgendwie jemanden, von dem man denkt, okay, der hat bei einem anderen Verein schlaue Sachen gemacht und würde jetzt halt zu Schalke wechseln, zu einem Club, der dann vermeintlich auf jeden Fall, also der dann größer wäre, der mehr Wucht hat, der sich da beweisen möchte. Dann hätte man halt wieder diese Frage, hält der diesen Druck bei Schalke 04 dann wieder aus? Und da hat man sich jetzt halt für jemand entschieden, der halt, der auch Politiker war, der halt durchaus, was Kommunikation angeht, was Networking angeht, da schon gewisse Erfahrungen mit sich bringt. Und hat natürlich André Hechelmann, der ja vorher der Sportdirektor war, den hat man ja behalten. Der macht ja die Dinge halt weiter. Wie gesagt, das ist in der Zeit nicht alles gut gelaufen, aber es ist natürlich auch nicht alles schlecht gelaufen. Also es war ja in der Phase zuvor auch so, dass André Hechelmann natürlich so Spieler gefunden hat, wie so ein Moritz Jens oder Tom Kraus oder so. Das sind ja Spieler, oder Derry Mürkin. Das sind ja Spieler, die hat ja André Hechelmann auch gefunden. Und das hat ja durchaus, diese Sachen haben ja auch gut funktioniert. Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt vorher alles dramatisch schlecht gelaufen ist oder dass man das alles an André Hechelmann hätte festmachen können, was da schlecht gelaufen ist. Insofern, ja, das ist die Hoffnung, die da bleibt. Was anderes kann ich hier dazu auch nicht sagen, leider.
Wie beurteilst du denn, Torsten, diesen Zielkonflikt, in dem man ja jetzt irgendwie notwendigerweise drinsteckt? Und zwar zwischen Überlebenskampf – nichts anderes ist es ja gerade – und der Notwendigkeit, dass man ja trotzdem etwas Langfristiges irgendwie anpeilen muss zumindest. Also ich persönlich zumindest aus Außenperspektive finde ja, das war der Kardinalfehler im Moment des ersten Abstiegs. Erster Abstieg habe ich vorher auch schon gesagt. Ich weiß, ihr wisst, was ich mit erster Abstieg meine. In der jüngsten Vergangenheit, dass man das eben nicht gemacht hat. Also man hat sich irgendwie mit Büstens dann zurück in die 1. Liga gewurstelt. Aber da ist dann eben aufgefallen, dass man keine Entwicklungsarbeit sozusagen geleistet hat. Und dann wurde das Ganze wieder schnell rückabgewickelt. Und das ist zum Beispiel Werder Bremen, die ja damals gemeinsam runtergegangen sind, deutlich besser gelungen. Da gab es ja auch totale existenzielle Sorgen. Ein großer Defetismus an der Weser, kann ich mich noch gut erinnern. Aber man hat sich da schnell festgelegt auf die Art von Fußball, die man spielen möchte und hat tatsächlich diese Identität über den Club gestülpt, die typische Werder Identität. Und hat es wieder herausentwickelt. Oder Werner hat den richtigen Trainer gefunden, blablabla. Aber ist ja nichtsdestotrotz etwas, was Schalke nicht gemacht hat und vielleicht jetzt irgendwie parallel machen muss, oder?
Also gebe ich dir erstmal komplett recht. Werder Bremen hat diese Fußballidentität, wenn gerade auch die Älteren, die jetzt schon länger dabei sind, wenn man sagt, wie spielt Werder Bremen Fußball, hat man direkt so ein Bild im Kopf. Und das ist bei Schalke tatsächlich nicht so. Und man muss trotzdem sagen, dass dieser Abstieg halt nicht vergleichbar ist, was die beiden Clubs angeht, weil der Downfall von Schalke 04 viel krasser war. Schalke ist damals mit einer Mannschaft abgestiegen, die eigentlich für Europapokalplätze vorbereitet war. Also, die hat Kosten verursacht wie ein Team, das eigentlich in Europa spielen soll. Und dann sind die innerhalb von anderthalb Jahren abgestiegen. Und man musste die Spieler loswerden. Also, die Spieler, die man damals in der ersten Liga hatte, musste man loswerden aufgrund der Gehälter. Das heißt, man konnte die nicht halten. Man konnte da keinen Stamm halten und sagen, okay, wir fangen in der zweiten Liga mit einem gewissen Stamm wieder neu an. Weil selbst die jungen Spieler, die damals kurzfristig noch Verträge bekommen hatten, haben die Verträge noch in der ersten Liga bekommen. Und in der ersten Liga sind die Gehälter einfach eklatan viel höher, sodass man die halt nur, wenn man vorher schon ahnt, okay, wir steigen ab, per Klausel dann irgendwie runtergradet. Dann kann man so Leute halt behalten. Aber das hatte Schalke nicht tatsächlich. Die sind abgestiegen und mussten ihren Kader austauschen. Und dann war die große Frage, okay, wie macht man es jetzt? Und dann hat sich Schalke halt dafür entschieden und hat gesagt, okay, wir haben halt so große finanzielle Probleme. Wir müssen halt schnell wieder aufsteigen. Und hat halt sehr viel mit Laien gemacht. Das heißt, sie haben sich viele Spieler geholt, die ausgeliehen waren, weil man dann natürlich bei einer Laie halt wahrscheinlich zumindest mal Spieler bekommen kann, die eine höhere Leistungsfähigkeit bis oben hin, also eine höhere Stealing haben, für weniger Geld. Zum Beispiel, genau. Und dann hat man sich halt Spieler geholt, wo man sich dann im besten Fall noch irgendwelche Optionen gesichert hat, die man hätte ziehen können oder so. Bei manchen hat das geklappt, bei manchen nicht und so. Aber man hat sich dann halt einen Kader zusammengeliehen. Und als man dann wieder aufgestiegen ist, musste man halt wieder neu planen. Und das war halt so ein bisschen das Ding, was halt die erste Phase nach dem ersten Abstieg dann halt so bestimmt hat. Dass man halt gesagt hat, okay, wir leihen uns die Spieler zusammen. Und hat dann aber keine Mannschaft neu aufgebaut so richtig. Und dann ist man jetzt halt hingegangen und hat gesagt, okay, das machen wir jetzt mal anders. Jetzt wollen wir halt Kaderwerte schaffen. Und jetzt gehen wir davon ab, Spieler zu leihen. Und hat jetzt halt angefangen einzukaufen. Dieser aktuelle Kader hat halt wenig Leihspieler. Wenig bis keine. Das heißt, Spieler wie Schallenberg und Seguil und Tempelmann wurden halt fest verpflichtet. Und man hatte so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das jetzt so eine Grundsatzfrage ist. Obwohl Verantwortliche immer gesagt haben, wenn es schon passt, dann würden wir es halt auch anders regeln. Aber bei vielen ist es halt so angekommen, dass es halt so eine Grundsatznummer ist. Er wurde nur geliehen, jetzt wird gar nicht mehr geliehen und irgendwie ist da kein so richtiger Flow drin. Aber das Problem mit diesem Aufbau und dem kurzfristigen Erfolg, das ist natürlich ganz klar gegeben. Aber man muss sagen, jetzt ist halt ein Kader zusammengekauft worden, der Schalke jetzt erstmal gehört. Und jetzt ist man halt verdammt, den halt auch weiter zu verfolgen. Das heißt, man muss jetzt da so einen Block finden, der dann halt funktioniert, wo man sagt, die Spieler am Ende der Saison wird man dann ja überlegen, was müssen wir jetzt verändern, was können wir aus der Nummer noch mit sich nehmen. Und ich glaube einfach, man hofft jetzt auf eine ordentliche Rückrunde, die natürlich noch möglich ist. Noch ist ja Zeit, dass mit dem neuen Trainer dann eben doch noch ein Spielsystem gefunden wird, wo man nachher sagen kann, okay, der und der und der, die drei, vier, fünf Leute, die passen gut und die sind unser neuer Block. Und ja, dann muss man halt wieder weiter basteln und neu anpassen. Ganz klar.
Aber das heißt, das, was Thomas ja eingangs erzählt hatte mit der übergestellten Fußball-Idee, also für sowas hat man wirklich dann jetzt gerade keine Zeit.
Ja, diese übergestellte Fußball-Idee ist ja auch immer so eine große Nummer. Ich glaube, das ist auch oft viel Mythos, oder? Also ich glaube, dass sowas mit dem Trainer halt kommt. Also so eine Fußball-Idee, dass ein Club sich die gibt, das gibt es halt in Teilen. Aber auch Werder Bremen hat natürlich, als damals da Thomas Schaaf rausgeschmissen wurde, erst mal drei oder vier andere Trainer geholt, die dann plötzlich mit einer ganz anderen Philosophie aufgetreten sind. Also das steht und fällt damit halt. Also der Fußball von Union Berlin wurde von Urs Fischer geprägt. Und wenn Urs Fischer da nicht aufgeschlagen wäre, hätte Union Berlin vielleicht einen ganz anderen Fußball gespielt. Das ist ja nicht so, dass das von vornherein auf dem Reißbrett festgemacht wurde. Und dann hat man sich den Trainer ausgesucht. So ganz so ist das dann halt doch nicht. Auch wenn viele Fans das, glaube ich, immer glauben und sich das irgendwie wünschen würden. Diese große Idee hat irgendwann mal einer gesagt, hat bei Ajax oder bei Barca die F-Jugend schon genauso spielt, wie die erste Mannschaft. Und seitdem sagen alle Fans, das muss bei Schalke nur viel genauso sein. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht realistisch. Das ist schon so, dass der Trainer natürlich derjenige ist, der ein Spielkonzept dann irgendwie entwickelt. Natürlich mit dem Sportdirektor. Natürlich sollte man sich überlegen, wen holt man sich, wofür steht der Trainer? Und dann da eine Linie reinbringen. Das ist der große Punkt, der bei Schalke nur viel dann auch häufiger mal nicht funktioniert hat. Weil man hat dann irgendwie – ich gehe jetzt nochmal in die Vergangenheit, aber das plastische Beispiel ist – Ralf Rangnick hat man verpflichtet. Der tritt zurück, weil er gesundheitliche Probleme hat. Und als nächsten Trainer holt man Huub Stevens, der irgendwie am anderen Ende der Fußballwelt von seiner Idee von Fußball anzusiedeln ist. Und solche Sachen haben sich halt immer wiederholt. Also es gab jetzt halt nicht unbedingt die Linie da drin bei den vielen Trainern, die Schalke geholt hat, dass man gesagt hätte, die stehen für dieselbe Art von Fußball. Das sollte man schon tun. Aber natürlich muss man das jetzt entwickeln. Und das entwickelt halt ein Trainer halt mit so. Und da ist jetzt Karel Gerrard derjenige, auf den ich da meine Hoffnung setze. Auch wenn es irgendwie plump klingt. Wer sonst? Das ist halt immer der nächste Trainer, der gerade kommt. Und das ist jetzt halt derjenige, welcher eben.
Ja gut, klar. Der aktuelle Trainer ist immer der, der am nächsten am Herzen ist. Aber wie groß würdest du denn die Kurve in der Linie von Thomas Reis zu ihm beschreiben? Jetzt, nachdem man jetzt ja schon ein paar Spiele gesehen hat. Vorher ist das ja immer so eine theoretische Diskussion.
Also ich glaube schon, dass der Ansatz ein anderer ist. Also mit Thomas Reis wurde halt schon – ich habe ja vorhin gefragt, wie das ist, wenn man Trainer hat, der hauptsächlich nach vorne denkt. Unter Thomas Reis war halt viel gegen den Ball. Da war echt viel gegen den Ball. Und was dann mit dem Ball passiert, wenn der Ball mal da ist, das ist nicht so richtig ausgearbeitet worden. Und Karel Gerrard ist da schon ein bisschen anders orientiert. Ich glaube, der denkt mehr mit dem Ball. Schalke hat halt gerade Probleme in der Defensive. Jetzt kann man wieder sagen, okay, dem fehlt jetzt auch die Balance. Das muss man nochmal abwarten. Die Spiele unter Karel Gerrard waren halt sehr unterschiedlich. Es gab Spiele dabei, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt konnte man schon erkennen, das soll in die richtige Richtung gehen. Und dann gab es wieder solche Rückschläge. Das Spiel gegen den HSV war aus Schalkersicht eigentlich ganz okay. Das ist halt verloren worden. Und dann hat man aber am Ende noch gesagt, okay, das war jetzt der HSV. Die sind irgendwie besser als irgendwie alle anderen. Da konnte man jetzt irgendwie so einen Haken dran machen. Das konnte man für sich verbuchen. Aber wenn man dann natürlich gegen Casas Lautern so eine Leistung hinterher schiebt, wo dann irgendwie erstmal gar nichts stimmt und wo man dann so auseinandergedröselt wird, ja, das ist dann natürlich eine Katastrophe. Und sowas wechselte sich in der Zeit mit Carre de Ferraz jetzt eben auch ab. Die letzten Spiele so gegen Führer und davor, das war ja völlig okay. Davor ist man eben von Düsseldorf auseinandergespielt worden. Und da ist halt noch keine so richtige Linie drin. Man hat sich dann halt erhofft, dass das natürlich im Wintertrainingslager zustande kommt, dass da die Linie reinkommt. Umso krasser war dann eben, dass dieses Kaiserslautern-Spieler eben so reingerauscht hat, wie ich gerade sagte. Also das HSV-Spiel konnte man sich dann noch irgendwie erklären oder hat man sich dann noch, ich sag mal, schön geredet.
Heieiei. Also HSV und Schalke, das sind echt so zwei riesige Themen. Das ist unglaublich, über wie viele Aspekte man da sprechen könnte. Ich habe eine abschließende Frage an euch beide. Das ist eine Transferfrage. Ich nehme ja hier aus Bayern heraus auf, da ist immer die letzte Frage in der Schulaufgabe, ist eine Transferfrage, die entscheidet zwischen 1 und 2. So ist das hier. Sogar schon in der Grundschule. Das ist ein ganz fantastisches System. Welche Eigenschaft, Torsten, vom HSV, würdest du dir für Schalke 04 wünschen?
Das variable Offensivspiel würde ich mir wünschen. Das, was Tim Walter eben vorne sehr kreativ hinbekommt, es schafft, da die Innenverteidigung der Liga auseinanderzuspielen, das würde ich mir halt für mein Club wünschen.
Und dann 3 zu 4 gegen Karlsruhe verlieren am 27. Spieltag zu Hause. Aber okay, ich verstehe deinen Punkt. Thomas, was würdest du dir von Schalke 04 für den HSV wünschen?
Das setzt jetzt so ein bisschen voraus, dass ich HSV-Fan wäre. Jetzt bin ich in dem Sinne vielleicht nicht. Aber was dem HSV, glaube ich, gut täte, wäre der Mut, auch schwierige und unangenehme Entscheidungen zu treffen. Und das ist, finde ich, in den vergangenen 2, 3 Jahren nicht so häufig passiert.
Sehr interessante Antwort. Ihr zwei, das war sehr interessant. Es hätte noch ewig weitergehen können. Ich habe irgendwann auf die Uhr geguckt und bin ein bisschen erschrocken. Da habe ich euch ein paar Minuten früher eigentlich versprochen, dass wir aufhören. Umso mehr danke ich euch beiden, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Ich werde natürlich verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Torsten Wieland, Friend of the Show, seit der ersten Folge. Haben wir ja mal rausgearbeitet, Torsten. Danke, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst. Und herzlichen Dank sensationell. Schön, dass du mal hier mit dabei warst. Danke, dass du dich gemeldet hast, Thomas Hürner. Sehr gerne sprechen wir noch ganz, ganz häufig über den HSV, vielleicht auch mal über Inter. Schön, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Bis demnächst.
Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei und wird getragen von Menschen wie Mark Briele, Saure Hefe 1887 – ist kein Zufall, dass du hier erwähnt wirst – Tobias Bönke, Rudi Thorben und Michael Rolando. Sie alle unterstützen uns nicht nur finanziell, sondern haben sich auch als Supporterinnen und Supporter registriert. Rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und auf rasenfunk.de da findet ihr all die Sendungen, die wir machen. Es ist wirklich eine ganze Reihe erschienen. Also zum Abschied von Jürgen Klopp haben wir eine Sendung veröffentlicht. Kai Bernstein habe ich schon erwählt. Natürlich dann Männer-Bundesliga, 1. Liga, die Frauen-1. Liga haben wir auch eine Sendung veröffentlicht. Und zum Afrika Cup haben wir auch neulich eine Sendung aufgenommen. Und da wird auch nächste Woche wieder was kommen. Also rasenfunk.de, da findet ihr Beschäftigung. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Macht's gut. Ciao. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Danke. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.